dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jonah if I hear who
or what is an impostor simple definition
a person who deceives others by
pretending to be someone else full
definition one that assumes false
identity or title for the purpose of
deception Wow the full definition is a
whopping seven characters more I don't
even know what to do with this amount of
time that I saved reading the simple
definition first let's look in the mind
of someone who suffers from impostor
syndrome and see the fickle
understanding they have of their own
achievements 98 points out of 100 this
surely means that they mixed up my
submission with someone else's who was
way smarter than I am I went in for the
next round of interviews messed up big
time and I got hired with an incredible
salary this can of course only be a
misunderstanding I got elected for this
prestigious award I don't know how this
could possibly have happened maybe
someone who really likes me try to
pressure the prize committee to vote for
me I cannot possibly imagine any other
way of this happening I've been five
years at this company now and still no
one found out that I'm a fraud that's a
disaster nothing can convince me that i
am not an imposter who fooled everyone
else for being a bright person however
funny as it may sound this is a very
real problem researchers academics and
high-achieving women are especially
vulnerable to this condition but it is
indeed not limited to these professions
for instance Hayden Christensen the
actor playing Anakin Skywalker in the
beloved star wars series appears to
suffer from very similar symptoms he
said I felt like I had this great thing
in Star Wars that provided all the
opportunities and gave me a career but
it all kind of felt a little too handed
to me I didn't want to go through life
feeling like I was just riding a wave so
as a response he hasn't really done any
acting for four years
he also said if this time away is going
to be damaging to my career then so be
it if I can come back afterward and claw
my way back in then maybe I'll feel like
I earned it the treatment of imposter
syndrome includes group settings where
the patients discuss their lives and
come to a sudden realization that they
are not alone and this is not an
individual case but a common pattern
among high achieving people as they are
also very keen on dismissing praise and
kind words they are instructed to be
more vigilant about doing that and to
try to take in all the nourishment they
get from their colleagues these are the
more common ways to treat this serious
condition that poisons so many people's
minds thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time